pour sommiers de la base tout au sol
dans son prix elle est là au premier
rang
de la vache il ya l'éleveur ya la peine
tu y as moi et ma faim type à la mesure
la mesure d' homme mon estomac et ma
faim qui par la mesure ne jure aussi mes
fins de mois
une vache à 1000 francs comme ce serait
charmant comme ce cher et charmant et
beaucoup plus tentants qu'une vache a
day in franc de machado en de masse à
1000 francs elle filait à 100 francs le
rhum c'est qu'à 60 francs le gîte à 40
francs laloyaux à 30 francs la culotte à
20 francs une culotte à 20 francs un
labo vagas francs la boîte mine à 12
francs l'apa bettany francs le voilier à
ouvrant le jarret haga frange arrêt à 4
francs serait intéressant et plus
avantageux pour faire un pot-au-feu d'un
jarret à 1000 francs un jarret agaçant
au deuxième de lavage
c'est à peine si je n'aperçois
au deuxième de la page y'a du monde
entre la bête et moi il ya le tueur qui
parle la mesure transporteurs qui lui
emboîte le pas
pendant que le ministre s'assure que la
viande de la vache
nous pas une vache à 1000 francs et
mendient dans le morbihan
de mouillage ma faisons comme par
enchantement une page à cent mille
francs on arrive à vraiment une vache à
5000 francs
on ne sait pas comment augmente de 20%
en traversant deux mois et bien par
conséquent il va aussi hommage à 6000
francs
c'est vous remonte en temps c'est nous
remontons temps pour les gens d'orléans
dans ses rues notamment une vache à lait
de vache à 10000 en sortant de la ville
oui dans un tourbillon devient ta rage
on va ma gueule que la bigne le vacherin
cent mille à montlhéry de george pisi
doit son nom à orly arrivant de famille
à la fois pour la vie lavage vélos rina
vachette aux gobelins et l'egypte liés
par 20 la redevance 52 au carrefour
richelieu et marc 810 est dans son camp
de la ville est aux derniers de l'apache
routine sous les balles
elle est là où tergnier tran de la vache
ya un monde entre samian des mois et
l'état pourront des mesures et à qui
veut
notre émoi il est à des mesures fait
monter un peu plus chaque mois
la vache à son front on va manger autant
autant qu'on en voulait plus qu'il ne
fallait amitié au dîner dans le café au
lait des vaches à 60 ans c'est déjà plus
chez nous on mange en moyenne 10 kg n
fois par contre autant je privais raison
de l'arrachage millevaches amis le
voient eux carrément se gaver d'ortolans
et souffrir dit omar tard il devient de
la vache à 2012 sera beau jour de l'an
pour la marge brute et sur un coin
canapé on regarde là le foie gras dont
les factures du mois de lavage à 5000
francs à diarra placement avec mes
lingots d'or dans un coffre fort jean
lassalle erding et les coûts pour le
bifteck la maja ça me fait mal car
décourageant les bretons soient méchants
des embauches ont pourtant il faudra
bien qu'on sache mieux puisque la mâche
à la 20è salvages la page
oh